gratidão sentimento bonito
acho que é um dos sentimentos mais
bonitos que o ser humano pode ter
eu sempre tive por muitas pessoas por
muitos motivos
eu espero que vocês tenham também a
minha gratidão é tão grande por algumas
pessoas e por alguns motivos que chega a
trazer um sentimento de dívida já
sentiram isso dívida moral
aquela vontade de retribuir algo para
alguém tem umas pessoas
essa foto revela a minha idade eu sou
esse moleque ali com cara de choro ao
lado do meu irmão com cara de sapeca não
gastar o meu pai minha mãe e os meus
avós
esses dois em especial meu pai minha mãe
e eu sempre tive muito esse sentimento
de dívida moral com eles de gratidão com
eles mesmo eles sempre me dizendo que
não filho não precisa a gente faz por
amor
eu digo sim precisa porque também é por
amor à minha gratidão e eu sempre tive
essa dívida moral eu sempre tive essa
sensação de que eu tenho que ajudar uma
mãe eu tenho que ajudar o papai eu quero
fazer isso eu sempre quis fazer isso e
vou contar uma historinha pra vocês
há uns anos eu queria uma empresa quando
não se falava ainda de marketing online
eu queria uma empresa de marketing
online chamada bistrô 60 site terrível
que eu mesmo fiz nessa época eu
trabalhei um tempo sozinho começou às
empresas sem dinheiro nenhum eu comecei
ela com o primeiro cliente assim como o
primeiro cliente ele me pagou foi o
capital inicial da minha empresa eu
comecei a trabalhar
trabalhei sozinho por um tempo depois eu
contratei a primeira funcionária que eu
acabei convidando pra ser minha sócia a
paula de minha em metade da empresa para
ela ea gente trabalhou muito forte
porque a gente queria dar muito certo
num tempo em que marketing online é uma
coisa que as pessoas não sabiam que era
principalmente as empresas
eu tinha que fazer palestras implorando
para os empresários abrirem uma conta no
facebook
você precisa estar lá não
o facebook é coisa de molecada onde já
se viu empresa séria não tem isso e eu
fiz muitas e muitas palestras falei
muito a respeito disso mas muito ea
gente conseguiu umas coisas legais
a gente tinha vários clientes na
carteira de clientes bem legal chegamos
a ter sete funcionários
trabalhamos muito forte em cima disso
durante muito tempo para alimentar esse
sonho só que eu nunca tirei dinheiro
desta empresa nem um centavo
eu nunca tive um problema bom eu nunca
tive um salário
todas as vezes que eu tinha o dinheiro
para tirar eu usava isso para contratar
um novo funcionário usava esse dinheiro
para colocar mais gente e fazer empresa
rodar mais rápido
como é que você começa uma empresa sem
capital inicial com funcionários com
carteira de clientes em dinheiro mas
você se mantém
eu me mantive esse tempo todo
monetizando meus hobbies
eu fazia tudo o que eu pudesse ganhar um
pouquinho mais dinheiro
tudo tudo tudo que tiver ao meu alcance
eu comecei a pegar as coisas que eu já
fazia por hobby que eu já gostava de
fazer por exemplo música e monetiza arte
monetizar eu sou formado em marketing
monetizar tudo eu fazia isso
mas claro fora do tempo fora do meu
tempo que eu gastava com o bistrô e eu
cheguei a ter nove trabalhos simultâneos
9 conta comigo número 1 que a equipe do
estrondo os nossos clientes na china
essa foto com a gente
o horário comercial de segunda a sexta
das 7 e 8 da manhã até seis sete oito da
noite todos os dias
número dois eu fazia técnico de som era
técnico de som numa casa noturna
lá no sul de santa catarina fazia-se
bico final de semana sexta sábado
domingo à noite
não preciso nem dizer que eu virava
madrugada né à noite o número 3
eu gravava a banda de amigos meus bandas
locais da cidade
gravei vários cds vários cds de bandas
locais ou de artistas locais que queriam
produzir
número quatro como eu sabia mexer no
photoshop sempre gostei de arte desenho
eu fazia cartazes de shows daquela casa
noturna que trabalhava para várias
outras
fiz mais de 400 capazes de festa para
fazer um dinheirinho extra número 5 eu
dava consultoria de marketing para
várias empresas profissionais liberais
sempre que sobrar um tempinho eu tinha
uma hora para fazer isso lá inclusive
uma das empresas que eu fui consultor de
marketing acabei virando se ou anos mais
tarde mas acho que esse assunto para um
outro tex
como se isso não bastasse eu ainda tinha
um selo de produção de filmes de moda eu
fiz mais de 60 fashion filmes x men na
itália em londres no méxico e era um
bico um trabalho paralelo para poder
fazer dinheiro para alimentar obstroem
agência
meu sonho era minha agência foi muito
ainda tinha três bandas a cura síria ea
sua torcidinha cada uma tinha sua rotina
de composição de gravação de show de
ensaio
eu não falei dormir nestes 96 viram né
é porque eu realmente não dormia não era
incomum uma vez ou duas vezes na semana
e ouvir a madrugada era bem fácil isso
acontecer
bom isso cobra um preço
teve uma hora que cobrou um preço de mim
também
um belo dia eu estava saindo do
escritório estava nos 7 funcionários meu
pai meu filho minha sócia todo mundo lá
gente saindo e eu sentia me senti mal
pela primeira vez eu nunca tinha me
sentido mal
eu me senti mal pela primeira vez um
pouquinho de falta de ar logo depois um
pouquinho de falta de ar a minha testa
encontrou-os o solo violentamente a
minha pressão estava 22
eu achei que ia morrer eu tinha certeza
absoluta que eu tava morrendo absoluta
a única coisa que eu conseguia pensar
naquele momento enquanto eu tentava
respirar o ar não vinha eu ficava e não
vinha a única coisa que eu conseguia
pensar eu escutava meu pai meu filho
gritando pessoal rasgou a camisa me
barbeio todo e eu só pensava assim toma
trouxa vai morrer no chão do lugar
que tanto trabalhou ninguém mandou
trabalho tanto na frente do teu filho
olha que ironia que bonita
thomas j a única coisa que eu conseguia
pensar
bom eu não morri vocês podem ver é não
morrer mas eu achei que eu ia morrer eu
tinha certeza absoluta que eu estava
morrendo que estava enfartando o tenor
smo avc qualquer coisa assim
eu tenho certeza que eu tava morrendo e
aí você não precisa morrer para mudar as
coisas na sua vida basta você ter você
achar que está morrendo e eu achei eu
tinha certeza disso e eu decidir fechar
a empresa
o que eu estava tendo longe de ser um
infarto longe de ser uma vez eu só fui
descobrir depois de mais seis e duas
para o hospital e iguaizinhos a essa mas
é preciso eliminar um monte de coisa na
minha vida eu decidi que o meu cnpj não
valia meu cpf ou cnpj para não encerrar
o cpf
fechei o bistrô 6 o nome do que eu tive
chama síndrome de burnout que você
queimar tudo que você tem na cabeça é a
última pontinha assim todo seu poder
físico e mental até o corpo dizer chega
de jogar no chão é uma doença do
trabalho que eu tive
e aí eu fechei bistrô
quando você fecha uma empresa sem ter
dinheiro guardado tem um nome bonito pra
isso chama-se falência
quebrei desse processo eu paguei mais de
150 mil reais de dívidas sem ter um real
para receber é o que eu tenho que fazer
é continuar fazendo aquilo que eu sabia
monetizar meus hobbies fazer tudo que eu
podia pra poder ajudar minha mãe meu pai
ainda era meu sonho ainda era o que eu
queria
preciso dizer que não dava certo
é claro que não dava certo patinei
patinei eu não fazer nenhuma coisa nem
outra eu nem consegui ajudar os meus
pais que também estava numa situação
ruim
minha mãe tinha acabado de fechar uma
lojinha que ela tinha estava todo
endividado também meu pai tinha ficado
doente perdido o emprego gastado muito
dinheiro com isso
estava numa situação bem ruim assim como
eu eu queria ajudar eles mas eu só
piorava o negócio porque eu queria
ajudar eles viviam mal porque é isso eu
sei que eles me viam assim
e eles ficavam pior por causa disso eu
via que ele estava mal por minha causa e
eu ficava pior ainda eles viram que ele
estava mal porque ele estava mal porque
eu estava mal e ela ficava pior ainda
e dá pra gente ficar uns 20 minutos
falando desse ciclo vicioso terrível
terrível eu comecei a fazer tudo que eu
sabia tudo que eu podia para monetizar
para poder ajudar eles pra poder me
ajudar e não conseguia nada disso
até que um dia ia acontecer uma coisa
muito legal
uma aeromoça salvou minha vida não é só
porque essa foto tirei do google mas
para uma tipo essa sim é uma moça dessas
no avião
eu estava me sentindo pior dos homens
dentro do avião a trabalho e assim eu
estava sentado na minha cadeira ali
esperando para viajar a trabalho
alguma coisa que provavelmente não
queria fazer não lembro que era mas eu
não queria falar eu queria ter em casa
com a minha família que ela salvou minha
vida
ela passou por mim eu estava sentado mal
na minha cadeira ali ela foi lá na
frente parou na frente de todo mundo não
sei se ela me viu mal talvez eu tenha
visto mas ela falou as palavras que
salvaram minha vida
ela falou assim em caso de
despressurização da cabine máscaras de
oxigênio caíram sobre as suas cabeças
puxa uma máscara para se liberar o fluxo
de oxigênio coloque sobre a boca o nariz
ajuste lá fica atrás da cabeça puxa as
tiras e respira normalmente se ao seu
lado estiveram uma criança em que
precisa de ajuda
coloque a máscara primeiro em você para
depois ajudar a quem precisa entender é
porque eu dei ênfase ela não deu a sair
fazendo dia ela falou o meio correto
assim mas coloca a máscara primeiro você
sabe você primeiro claro idiota que tá
tentando salvar o mundo como é que vai
salvar alguém
mas eu não tinha entendido isso até
então eu cheguei a tuitar eu passei ali
eu cheguei botar no meu twitter anos
depois quando estava escrevendo sobre
isso tem que salvar a si mesmo primeiro
pensa comigo tá acontecendo um celular
um negócio no avião caiu a oxigênio da
cabine
todo mundo apavorado todo mundo gritando
tem uma criança do teu lado apavorar
acabei errando porque ela não sabe o que
tá acontecendo cai a máscara lado o teto
você vai lá e tenta ser o herói do dia
colocar a máscara na criança
ela está apavorada ela se debate não
deixa você colocar a máscara
aí você fica sem ar e desmaia a criança
fica sem ar e desmaia
morrem os dois fim da história a segunda
opção mesmo forums acontecendo
a gritaria a criança estava apavorada
cai a máscara
você lembra da aeromoça você puxa para
liberar o fluxo de oxigênio coloca sobre
a boca nariz ou elásticos tira tudo
bonitinho daquela bela respirada
oxigênio puro ea criança ali do seu lado
gritando apavorada mas servirá para
aquela boca
ela se assusta para você coloca mas
canela os dois se salvam fácil assim não
é bombeiro fala isso né não aumenta o
problema se você não sabe salvar não vai
lá no momento o problema se salva
primeiro garante que você está salvo se
não são dois problemas
se você se sustenta se é livre até para
ajudar os outros
isso mudou minha vida eu virei outra
pessoa vê outro leandro com menos cabelo
mas outro leandro porque eu comecei a
tentar me sustentar primeiro e daí saiu
a minha profissão hoje eu sou educador
financeiro comecei a ensinar as pessoas
a não fazer as borradas que eu fiz e a
reverter para quem já fez burrada como
eu tinha feito
saiu a profissão que eu amo fazer deste
problema o que eu faço hoje o que eu
gosto tanto de fazer
saiu de lá mudou minha vida e aí a
partir daí eu comecei a conseguir ajudar
as pessoas ao meu redor
olha que legal porque eu me preocupei me
salvar primeiro parece tão óbvio né
minha profissão de educação de educação
financeira encontram os tabus dinheiro
um tabu para muita gente
dinheiro não é bonito ser rico não é
bonito né vai alguém que veio de uma
família pobre e ficou rico sei lá um
cantor um músico uma
tá vai na televisão o apresentador do
programa falou que ele veio de família
humilde
quer dizer que agora que têm dinheiro
deixaram de ser humildes não né ele vem
de família pobre
agora ele é de família rica tá tudo
certo pobre e humilde são dois objetivos
diferentes
uma coisa não tem nada a ver com você
pode ser ricky humilde você pode ser
pobre humilde e pode ser pobre arrogante
henrique arrogante mas a gente tem esse
tabu de que dinheiro é ruim e dinheiro
não é ruim e riqueza não é ruim se eu
pegar um bilhão de dólares e da na mão
da dona zilda arms uma das maiores
benfeitores que esse país já viu
fundadora da pastoral da criança ela vai
ficar ruim por causa de um bilhão de
dólares
ela vai ser um bilhão de dólares melhor
um bilhão de vezes melhor ajudando mais
gente e ela faleceu coitado mas seria
muito melhor agora se eu pegar esse
mesmo bilhão ainda na mão de pessoas
como al capone como hitler
eles vão virar bonzinho eles vão ser
bonzinhos assim vão ser os novos donos
de bares vão ser cada vez piores é um
bilhão de vezes piores porque o dinheiro
não é ruim e ele não tem culpa de nada a
riqueza não é ruim não tem culpa de nada
é o que a gente faz com ele
é o que está dentro da nossa cabeça e
quando a gente quer salvar o mundo a
gente às vezes demoniza essa relação com
o dinheiro com riqueza porque a gente
precisa salvar o mundo de alguma outra
forma que a gente não sabe o que não
sabe como ea gente nem se salvou ainda
um outro cara bacana que fala muito bem
sobre isso aqui com a própria vida dele
é o cara que criou a microsoft windows
bill gates
esse cara tem uma fortuna de quase 100
bilhões de dólares 1 bilhão é muita
coisa sabe quanto é um bilhão se você
quiser contato 1 bilhão um número por
segundo
leva mais de 30 anos a contar de 1
bilhão 1 bilhão é muita coisa esse cara
tem uma fortuna estimada na casa dos 100
bilhões ele já doou um terço disso 30
milhões
e ele já declarou em vida e até o final
da vida dele ele vai doar tudo daria
para fazer o contrário
primeiro ele doou 100 bilhões depois ele
faz 100 bilhões
não dá né primeiro a gente salva coloca
a máscara de oxigênio na gente
a gente parte para salvar o mundo
primeiro antes de tentar arrumar o mundo
a gente arruma nossa própria cama
e aí a gente sai para consertar o mundo
se eu puder deixar só uma dica record na
cabeça de vocês hoje ou amanhã o projeto
da vida de vocês salvem a si mesmo o
primeiro
obrigado
[Aplausos]